and happy to have
J talking about stability and networks
yes okay so welcome so
first uh this will be the same talk that
I gave in the slm of the hill in
September H I heard that yeah so if you
were already there you can just not pay
attention so it's fine um and also this
this book that we are celebrating with
this Workshop you the Market design book
has a chapter about trading networks so
now we can say that oh it's somehow
related to that chapter where is my
clicker okay
so tring networks uh we had three papers
and three of these people planer yo tag
and boy we are the fixed points that are
all of three in three papers and tamura
schotter and r CH b b b Paper so that's
why I wrote it like this and two of the
papers are published and one is not
published um should I
start so we want to talk about tring
networks so you remember the usual
two-sided matching market like men and
women hospitals
residents or firms and workers but want
to add some extra twist and extra twist
is that instead we are talking about
trading networks so imagine that you
have something like a supply chain or
something so there are
some uh sellers the sellers are selling
to intermediates intermediates are
selling to some other intermediates and
in the end they will reach the final
consumer so one version is like a sfly
chain can be
like this like a cyclic another version
that we like in this paper it might
contain some Cycles so in this example
we have a core Factory that is selling
something to power pant and so on and so
on and in the end it come back to the co
Factory and um so each time somebody's
selling something to somebody else it
doesn't have to be the same good so
maybe the cor factur is Buy coal for
some place and selling energy so it
doesn't have to be the same thing that
they're
selling
um now so I always tell people just this
is a directed graph just just imagine a
directed graph we have the nodes those
are the firms and we have the directed
edges those are the
contracts and each directed Edge has a
buyer and a seller so
yes let's say this is buyer of contract
X this is
seller so far so
good
and like this you have set of contracts
on a graph it can contain parallel edges
if you want and it can also contain like
edges going back and forth between the
same firm so it it can contain whatever
we want um and let's say this guy is
firm F and firm f
is has two incoming edges and two
outgoing edges so it has a possibility
to buy two goods and selling two goods
but we will see that this guy has some
kind of a choice function so probably
they won't want to buy everything and
sell everything but pick the favorite
subset so we will call XF that those
contracts to that belong to firm
F and they will call
it Economist will call it dancing
contracts mathematicians will call it
outgoing edges and for these economists
will call it Upstream contracts and
mathematicians we call it incoming
edges and everybody will have a choice
function so every node in the graph has
a choice function fun like um you
remember like
in students and the colleges the
students have a preferences over when
they want to go and the colleges have a
preferences over who they want to
accept this time the extra truth is that
we have incoming and outgoing edges and
we have Choice function over the
incoming and outgoing edges so what is a
choice function just simply uh contract
set X has all the possible subsets and
for any possible subset we have a chosen
subset so here are something that is
offered to me and this is my chosen
subset and we call something IRC here
IRC means irrelevance of rejected
contracts which means okay using this
beautiful picture if I have set
why this is my con choos and set Choice
c y and z is somewhere in the between it
means that out of Y my favorite subset
is c
y and z is something is the smaller so
if this is the sav subset out of all the
subsets in y then it will be also the
favorite subset among the subsets of Z
so it's believable it it's often happens
and um actually if you write the
preferences like that that you have a
strict ordering over all subsets then
obviously this will be true but if you
would like to represent it in some other
way sometimes it can fail I want to tell
you an example when it fails like
imagine that you have
colleges and here is like two students
student one student two I just want to
show it this guy has zero points in the
admission exam this guy also has zero
points in the ex exam and here the quota
is one and let's say this is contract a
contract B then like a choice out of a
would be hiring a the choice out of B be
hiring B but the choice A and B together
would be the empty set this this is like
the Hungarian College admission system
because if you buy higher boats then you
exceeded the quota that's not good and
if you hire one of them it's not equal
treatment anymore so you have to reject
everybody so this would
uh that would not be IRC anymore I just
wanted to show that is not
IRC no we are back back to the normal
IRC so all the time in this paper or in
the stock we will use IRC irrelevance of
contract and other thing that we will
always use is substitutability but it's
a special kind of
subil so let's say here you
have offered contracts here is my
favorite set which is I'm buying one
good and selling one good and a f will
mean the set of rejected contracts so
it's like this
um okay and again back to the two-sided
Market what you all already heard about
substitutability substi means that if I
have a bigger set then what I'm
rejecting expands so if I can choose
from let's say again students there are
five students and the quota is three I'm
hiring the best three students according
to the preference order but if there are
10 students
applying and they already contain the
previous five students that those two
guys who were rejected before will be
still rejected and some other people
will be rejected too so the set of
rejected people is expanding that's
substitutability um
but we will change this because now we
have incoming and outgoing
edges and it's not that simple anymore
because instead just normal
substitutability you have same size
subtit and cross side
complementary so it's
like I'm selling things those are
substitutes to each other but selling
something and buying something is
complements to each other I like to if
I'm buying more things I want to sell
more things so you can see here in this
definition but I also show you in the
this little
example um it's first um these are the
offered
set and I can buy one good and sell two
goods and I only want to buy one and
sell one so I'm rejecting this Edge in
the bottom but now I can one side
expanded the outgoing Edge is expanded
what I rejected before I'm still
rejecting on the the selling side and it
can happen that I'm rejecting something
else too so the same side
substitutability happened on the same
side
I that was substitutable yes and cross
ey
complimentary originally I'm rejecting
something so I don't want to sell this
good here on this Edge
but
if originally I I had an offer said the
two incoming edging so I could buy two
things if instead I can only buy one
thing that it makes sense that I'm only
also selling less than before so I'm
rejecting what I rejected before and it
can happen that I'm rejecting something
else as well all the thing together so
SS same size substitut cross side
complementary together we call it full
substitutable and we have a bunch of
different stability
Concepts um
first if we talk about what is a
trail
um again in a directed graph you can
have a path or a
trail so
that's make a set of contracts that is
coming after each
other if you have something like that I
would call it a path but if you are also
allowed to repeat some
nodes I will call it a
trail so we will use trails in our
definitions
and here you are allowed to repeat nodes
but you are not allowed to repeat edges
if you would also repeat edges then I
would call it a walk so like Trail is
the middle type of definition
and like you can imagine you start
somewhere and then you walk on that
trail okay this is a special case we
will use it later so imagine that you
have a flow like you know the maximum
flow problem you learned earlier
like food for an algorithm find a
maximum flow somewhere in a graph we are
doing something
similar but
now
um so the again the edges are the
possible
contracts uh s is the source T is the
Target and every node except for S and T
satisfies kof's law that means that they
have a preferences like that that they
want to buy as money Goods as they are
selling so for example this guy in the
middle maybe they are buying zero or
selling zero or buying one thing and
selling one thing or buying two things
and selling two things but for T because
it's a Target the T just accepts
everything that is offered so it's like
the choice function is that I accept
everything all the
time and also it's also special in a way
that now we have strict orderings on the
incoming edges and the outgoing edges so
for example if you offer for this middle
node like this this and and this first
choice because of the K flow it has to
pick one incoming and one outgoing so it
will pick this outgoing Edge and this
incoming Edge but if you order all four
edges then it will pick all four
edges so in this before defining very
precisely what is the tra table outcome
just just look at this
picture
um now it satisfies ke slow so it's
actually a flow that's okay it's a flow
but I don't think this is stable why is
it not
stable because this note here would
happily switch
to selling the First Choice instead of
the second choice this note here is just
if you can buy one thing and sell one
thing instead of doing nothing then yeah
I accept buying one thing and selling
nothing and we said that the target
accept everything so the target is also
happy so instead we switch to this
outcome and I think this is stable now
because this is not blocking this is
also not blocking path together is also
not
blocking this Edge is also not blocking
if a second and this thir so so I would
say that this is a TR stable
outcome
okay and and yeah also different special
case is subal chains so I would say that
in in this talk when I say supply chain
I mean that something is a cyclic and
when I say trading Network then trading
Network can also contain Cycles so here
something is s like
and okay um first I want to Define chain
stability because that appeared in
ostrov's paper in 2008
so take an outcome outcome is a subset
of the edges it is inv rational if for
every firm it's it's okay so they accept
what they have right now and there is no
Trail in a way that I offer this Trail
and everybody who is involved they would
say that together with the existing
outcome the trail is offered so I I
would accept all the pges that I
included for me
inside the
trail
um and in this case when everything is a
cyclic then it's very nice so in an
acyclic network if we have full sub
security and IRC there is always a chain
stable outcome and it was shown by
OSI and uh we can also Define something
like set stability but we can we will
also just say stable so something is
stable if not looking at Trails but any
kind of set um here you have your okay
it's in rational everybody is happy with
what they have right now and there is no
blocking set blocking set is kind any
kind of set of contract you you offer it
then all of the people who are involved
in the set would say yes yes I accept it
so I we could could call it set stable
or we could just call it
stable and you can see that one of them
talked about Trails another talked about
any kind of set so it's little bit a
different
definition
and so it headfield Comer's paper they
showed
that the allocation is stable if and
only if it's chain stable and since if
you have an asy click Network you
already had the proof for chain
stability so with the same thing so it
impli I that there is always the stable
outcome and somewhere else I'm not sure
if I have the correct citation or or is
it was proven somewhere else but they
also showed that
um even if it's not a cyclic anymore but
in some other tring network then
stability and chain stability will be
the same
thing so for set stability or just
stability you can have any kind of
blocking set the sad news is that there
is not always a stable outcome and this
is a small counter example that was also
in the Hat whe Comer's paper that you
have just one cycle plus one extra Edge
so what happens now uh this guy J
prefers outgoing Edge X to outgoing Edge
Z so if the starting outcome is just the
cycle
alone then it's not good because X is a
block X alone is a blocking contract
because J would happily switch and I
would also
accept contracts X instead of having
nothing so that's not good that is a
blocking Edge but if you start from the
empty set that's also not good because
then the cycle is blocking because K is
happy to accept the cycle and J is also
happy to accept the cycle instead of the
empty set like z and y alone is better
than nothing so there is always some
blocking set so we are sad that there is
no stable
outcome and we also showed I will come
back to it later that in this case
determining if the outcome is stable is
MP complete so it's it's hard to decide
what is
stable now a favor
that is we like the most is tra
stability um so again you have a TR
Network you can define a trail but now
we are looking talking about a locally
blocking TR what is a locally blocking
imagine that this is like contract
a contract B I don't care about this
let's say c d whatever
EF uh
and we say
that A and B together is good do you
accept it let's say we have some
existing outcome that we haven't but we
also have this so A and B together if I
offer it alongside the existing outcome
it's
accepted and later I come back and I
only care about the local part so just
two edges after each other so if I offer
E and F together is it accepted yes so
then it's locally
blocking um and we will say that an
outcome is Trail stable if there is no
locally blocking
Trail
okay but the trick is here that that
here we never asked
about a b and EF alone we we don't care
if it's acceptable or not but for
mathematical reason this will work fine
so we call it a shortterm stability
notion so we we we check
the two edges after each other and and
then we Define
traceability the good news is that there
will be an existence result so we make a
trail just step by step you check if
it's accepted and it also has to have a
beginning so for the
first first person in the trail you you
just only need to check if a alone is
acceptable alongside the the existing
contract and that's F G H that's a I
here you also need just need to check
the this one alone that is it acceptable
or
not and so I'm saying that if uh the
preferences satisfy full subtit
stability and IRC then there is always
exist a tra stable
outcome and FJ that
means
um
and I'm not going to prove this but I'm
kind of giving you the sketch of the
proof when I was going to the class of
Alex and I actually showed the proof on
the Whiteboard
um
so just for the sketch of the proof we
want to use tar fix point because we
really like tasky fix point theem so
Define the ltis with the tricky partial
order where the tricky partial order
means that you have two parts and the
first part is expanding and the second
part is
decreasing and we will have the F
function or fi okay the FI function
which which means that if you are
starting from a set y z z then it's
rejected so that all of the contracts
minus what was rejected and this
notation means that I'm looking at only
the set Z for the incoming edges and I'm
only looking at the set y on the
outgoing edges so you just combine these
together and we will say that okay this
will be a isotone or monotone function
with respect to the tricky partial order
and if you have a monotone function and
a ltis you can use tarsky fix Point
theorem is that
good just a little bit more slowly so so
RS z y is out of Z you are looking at
the outgoing ones that you reject uhhuh
yes something like that why the
opposite it's a weird notation sorry
um
actually it looks like is the
product of
the um of the subset of the outgoing
that
you reject and all the incoming
times
of the wi the ones the incoming that you
reject and all the
outgoing and I go to an example and I
show you there okay so here I had
a what was the
example
complicated
[Music]
the I get confused by your
question
no I think this was the
picture contct x y
z
w
and something like this okay I will pick
let's say set Z will
be X and v w set y will be now I'm
looking at the second line here
everything and I I use my notation for
myself that actually Z is always
something with the
sellers and why is always something with
the
buyers
buyers so
if I'm on the seller side I just care
about this and this and on the buyer
side I care about
everything this dot means that which
Edge end of the thing that I'm looking
at so for this
node um I'm looking at something like
incoming edges
are Y and W and the outgoing edges are
just looking at x alone because okay so
from here I'm looking
at the everything so this white thing
and here I'm only looking at the
Z and um from this what would I
choose um and what would I
reject um
I would say that the choice function
let's say Choice function from this
would be buying one thing and selling
one thing
and maybe in this
example X and V was the best thing so X
was the first choice that
was also this
first choice are you your example h
example which not is that one uh in the
example J is this one because that has
the most things listed so that has four
contracts and everything else has just
one two contract so then I would select
the and X
together and I'm rejecting okay what I'm
rejecting is
uh like this I rejected
y
ah okay something like this
um what I'm doing
here okay so
actually RS means that I'm only looking
at the seller side
rejections but here Z means seller side
and y means buyer side and here the same
thing but I'm only looking at the buyer
side rejection and here this is buyer
and this is seller so always Z is the
seller just with the stupid notation
sometimes the order is Switched and this
means
that here input is Y and Z output
is everything minus what is rejected on
the buyer side everything minus what is
rejected on the sell side and that has
to be a fixed Point somehow
um maybe let's try if I had it
correctly
is why was on the buer
side
and I wasting
it I think okay okay
sorry um okay so we do something like
this and in the end we will find a fixed
point because of tari and we can also
say that we show show that the fixed
point will correspond to a three stable
outcome so if y z would be fix
point you take the
intersection a intersection C and I say
this outcome will be a th
outcome
and another thing that we can do is just
almost the same thing just with a little
bit change that instead of
the pi function we look at the T
function but even if you do at a t
function you will get the same solution
again T
point and okay the this is what I showed
on this whiteboard
that the sad story here
is somehow these fix points are not
unique so here you have this is a table
outcome and you have a one corresponding
y z fix point and these are always the
same thing but you have three
corresponding fix point so it's kind of
not not very
nice uh and I WR bua is a problem for me
it's a problem for me because
um in the two-sided Market everything
was so beautiful because in the
two-sided Market again you had
the why no the fee type of choice
functions or the T versions and in the
two-sided Market if you could find the
fix point for a given stable outcome it
was unique but in the trading Network
model it's not unique anymore so we had
something nice
earlier
um you have a like um stable matchings
men and women and you define some Choice
functions and some T function and you
look at the for the fixed point and you
can say that for a given stable
outcome um what we will find that y z
together is a fixed point of T and it
creates the given a then for a given a
has to be only one y and only one Z that
will satisfy this that's that's what I
this I didn't prove it here but maybe I
can prove it to you
later so somehow here you you connection
with while stable outcomes is not unique
yes here here
it's the connection between the
connection is not un anymore yes but
even in the simple marriage problem even
in the simplest marriage problem you
only have generic
uniqueness and only generic generic that
is for almost every choice of the
parents no she she's not talking about
the uniqueness of
she's talking about the connection
between these two objects between the
outcome and this
set yes yes yes yes the fix Point
there's a connection between a and why
is that
fair 10 minutes I will speed up thank
you okay so the speed up version for the
remaining part is
that terminal agents I'm also interested
in terminal agents and something is a
terminal buyer if they only buying
things something is a selling or seller
if they are only selling things and
looking at just the
terminal
of
nodes I want to Define buyer optimal and
seller optimal things and thanks to this
lest result with tki fix Point theorem
we can say that there's always a buyer
optimal tra stable outcome and there is
always a seller optimal tra stable
outcome and we also want to Define some
kind of partial order and the partial
order will be that something is seller
Superior if all the sellers are happier
but all the buyers are worth of and
buyer Superior is the opposite that all
the buyers are happier and these are
opposite to each other because we Define
it that way and for this ter a
superiority partial order we want to
have some kind of laes but it's not
really working um so first we
use you know the law of aggregate demand
now instead we have law of aggregate
demand than Supply so it's number of
contract on the buyer side minus one
number of contract seller side is
increasing with respect to some the vi
partial
order and
okay here we have some kind of result
that that this Fe function that we
defined earlier if we have lad loss so
low of aggregate demand and Supply then
the fix Point form a suce for for for of
the big lce so suce means that the union
and meat operations are
kept and this is my conjecture
that we were working on it a lot but
it's still still not working um that for
this terminal superiority partial order
we would like to have something like
that that it forms a lce so all the
possible outcomes would be would be a
lce for for this terminal superiority
but we didn't prove it what we prove
something um easier we prove instead
that
you you you are using p ability and low
of aggregate demand and Supply then you
are only looking at the sellers only
looking at the sellers and don't care
about the buyers of at all then for the
sellers you have a so that is property
and if you're only looking at the buyers
and you don't care about the seller side
again just for the buyers we have a lot
property
um and
I would I would say everything quickly
so if somebody is not very happy about
the the original definition of Trail
stability because we were only looking
at the locally blocking
um blocking pads we have some kind of
other definition that can fix it so our
other definition is that you are looking
at the first first some contracts or the
last so it's like
the initial part or the ending part so
like what I had earlier but I
erased and if you
had a b c DS
possible uh contracts for one given node
you are checking if ABCD let's say ABCD
AF you're checking if AB alone is
accepted yes
a b c d together is accepted yes A B C D
E F so you are only checking the initial
segments in if the initial segments are
always good then we will say that it is
a blocking Trail and what we Define here
is weekly Trail
table and because we called it weekly
tra table that already says that some
somehow it's weaker than what we had
before so we can show
that if something is weakly tra stable
then it's also tra stable but not the
other way around so for example here
um the together this cycle is both V T
table and TR table but the empty set is
weekly Trace stable because this thing
here is does not satisfy this new
definition with the initial segments but
it satisfies the locally blocking thing
because XY is good together and ZW is
good together so it is not Trail stable
anymore five minutes five minutes
okay so comparing to stability what we
had in the beginning so any kind of
blocking
set is it always traceable no because
these exist and the other things the
normal stability doesn't always exist so
if you are looking at this counter
example uh no ST stable outcome exist
because it's my earlier example plus one
Edge which is doesn't really make sense
and but this W alone is Traer stable
because there is no blocker blocking
Trail because a cycle alone would be
blocking but cycle is not allowed
because the trail has to start somewhere
and end somewhere to be a locally
blocking
Trail and okay just for the last five
minutes uh we had this complexity
results so if you have a special case a
flow Network
like everything is defined as with
satisfying kof flow the in this flow
Network it is MP complete to decide if
it has a pet or cycle stable
outcome and for this special flow
networks P or cycle stability will be
the same as stability therefore it is
also emply complete to decide if it has
a stable outcome or not and we can also
do the same thing for General um
preferences so if you have some kind of
trading Network where the preferences
are fully substitutable and
IRC then there are two things one is
that here is the question decide does it
have a a stable outcome or
not deciding that is also MP hard and
also there is another question the
testing a given outcome I give you an
outcome and say test it can you find a
blocking set and just testing the
instability of a given outcome that's
also MP complete so both questions here
are hard to
compute and so
conclusion we saw a lot of stability
defici if the the project if you have an
aycc supply chain then all of the years
are the same if you have Cycles then
usually are not the
same and we want to brag about St
stability a bit because tra stability we
have existence result and it's easy to
find because you can iterate a monotone
function and the monotone function will
find somewhere and that fixed point will
give you a stable outcome while if you
are looking at stability doesn't always
ex exist and it's empty hard to time
okay and this is what I wanted to say
thank you for your
attention thank you on
questions all right I'm going to be the
next speaker and the last
one I take this opportunity to thank